Donald Trump was in Scotland what a week
and a half ago he said that brexit is a
great victory for not just the UK but
for all of Europe and for the United
States what's the cross over in your
mind between the success that was had
with the referendum and Donald Trump and
the crossover is I guess that people
like myself have taken on difficult
issues that the normally early correct
class have tried to bury under the
carpet and we've made them political
debating points and Trump has done that
I wouldn't find you know there are some
issues on which we wouldn't see eye to
eye but he has challenged the consensus
charge so anti-establishment that's
what's the same in the UK and that's
what he represents in the u.s. even
though he's a multi-millionaire and has
been giving money to politicians since
the attack yeah but he's up against
Hillary you know and Hillary kind of
takes this attitude that I'm entitled in
this job it's part of my so hereditary
right to have this job so she is the
establishment cabin and what's the
difference Nigel between what's going on
in the UK and what you see happening in
the United States well you know the u.s.
is having a big political debate in the
run-up to you know this this this
election the UK's problems have been far
more serious in the US now we've
literally given away control of our
country given away the ability to make
laws opened up our borders to half a
billion people and assets of our
referendum last week was a very big
moment and in one way Trump is right
it's a seismic event not just in Britain
not just in Europe but in the world